all right welcome to CBS this morning we
begin this morning with breaking news
fire and snow are causing major
disruptions in the western US parts of
Colorado could see heavy snowfall from a
storm that's expected to move into the
Upper Midwest tonight and reach the
Northeast by Thanksgiving and overnight
the latest wildfire in Southern
California has put thousands of people
under mandatory evacuation orders this
so-called cave fire exploded overnight
in Santa Barbara County forcing
officials to declare a local state of
emergency they're more than three
thousand acres have burned so far and
the flames are quickly approaching
residential areas Jonathan Vigliotti is
near the scene of that fire Jonathan
good morning so what are the conditions
where you are yeah good morning to you
Tony we're here at a safe location
watching as these massive flames ripped
through this mountainside at this hour
they're contained to a pretty remote
area but the big concern this morning
high winds in some cases up to 30 miles
an hour carrying these burning embers
ahead of the blaze and sparking hotspots
it's why this place was able to grow to
over 3,000 acres as you mentioned in
only a few hours we're actually here on
one of the front lines with first
responders they're watching these flames
to see which direction they go in right
now 2400 homes are threatened 6000
people under a mandatory evacuation take
a look at this video from one woman as
she was fleeing her home you see all
those burning embers blowing around her
and in some cases flames coming up along
the roads it's unclear what sparked this
fire the power was actually turned on at
the time Southern California Edison has
since cut it off to a thousand customers
consider this this is the 60 second
hundred wildfire incident in this state
this year alone governor Newsom says
he's closely watching this a local
emergency has been declared but there's
another big concern here and it's always
dry brush much of it has not burned in
over 25 years the big concern these
flames being carried by the wind down
into the valley where Jericka there are
thousands of homes Wow unbelievable
thank you Jonathan